so we're fighting a corona virus
pandemic but what about the swarms anime
far more than any human form
even in bad Hollywood movies bugs make
our skin crawl but when they're real and
there's a code of 19 pandemic that's a
huge problem that just got worse and
right now the UN says swarms son as big
as a city are eating their way through
Pakistan and Horn of Africa
so can we stop this plague of locusts or
will the corona virus ruin any chance of
getting these swarms under control
[Music]
so while we've been stuck inside because
of the coronavirus outside there's been
a plague of locusts locusts are like
grasshoppers on steroids under the right
conditions some of these members of the
grasshopper family morph into locusts
[Music]
this plague is threatening the crops and
livelihoods of tens of millions of
people
Kenya hasn't had it this bad in 70 years
Ethiopia and Somalia haven't seen
anything like it in 25 locusts are also
in Eritrea Uganda and South Sudan the
threat dates back to 2018 when wet
weather led to a population explosion
and with the rainy season the UN says
the number of locusts could increase by
20 times if you were mentioned that the
one square kilometer you or 50 million
individuals then you can calculate how
many there are eat up billions and
billions of locusts and the timing is
horrible their arrival in the Horn of
Africa coincides with the main planting
season yet the drop in South Sudan even
before the locusts invaded 5.3 million
people couldn't get enough to eat a
peace deal had raised the prospect of
more farmers planting this season but
now this is the perfect time for the
swarms to destroy all the crop lands
unless we take measures the food
insecurity in a situation of from the
next coming in scenario will be the
worst so what's behind the swarm why now
well many people say it's shifting
weather patterns because of global
warming so we looked into it big
cyclones in the Arabian Peninsula are
rare there have only been three in the
last 50 years that was until May 2018
that's when cyclone and mikono hit
followed by cyclone Lubin only five
later together they dumped enough water
across four countries to create an ideal
breeding ground for the locusts probably
enough for about three generations of
breeding so over a nine-month period so
that's roughly about 8,000 fold increase
in locusts between about June of 2018
and March of 2019 then last December on
another cyclone hit northeastern Somalia
and eastern ethiopia is it all because
of climate change
hard to say a hundred percent but what
we do know is this there's a climate
system that affects that part of the
world it's called the Indian Ocean
dipole but when it turns to positive
phase it causes more extreme rainfall
and more frequent cyclones and what
scientists think is happening is that
climate change is making this positive
phase of the IOD more very happening if
this trend continues then yeah we're
gonna get more localized outbreaks so
how exactly do these conditions create
swarms of desert locusts well when it
looks like a grasshopper it's green
prefers to be alone and can't fly far
but bunched together like when they
start to run out of food there's the
potential for real trouble crowding
causes the grasshoppers to brush up
against each other and can activate
special hairs on their back legs that
send signals to the
central nervous system it releases a
neurotransmitter called serotonin that
triggers all sorts of changes in how the
grasshoppers behave and how they look
they develop larger wings turn yellow
and grow to about the size of your index
finger even their brains get bigger
well they don't get smarter but you know
their behavior changes and they changed
from being a solitary head home to
gregarious and all that's one of the
changes but the other change is also
that they eat many more different plants
they also like to move more as
underdeveloped insects they live in
about 30 countries but transformed the
desert locust can spread to twice that
many it can end up as far as Portugal in
Spain they have such an ability to fly
100 meters 200 kilometres 80 20 feet and
that makes them one of the most
dangerous migratory species they don't
acquire visas not requests for it we
just moved and now they've moved into
Pakistan the government there has
declared a state of emergency because
agriculture represents about one-quarter
of GDP is me nice idea for Sunday to
detangle yeah Kanaka let's say my each
other Oh
Kaguya and the covert 19 pandemic is
complicating things in Somalia
pesticides expected at the end of March
have been delayed because of cargo
flight restrictions in Kenya lockdowns
have messed up the delivery of
pesticides fewer flights means shipping
costs have reportedly tripled in some
cases to control the swarms people in
the past have actually suggested using
giant Nets flamethrowers lasers and huge
vacuums some say we should just eat them
I'm told locusts are a good source of
protein
[Music]
but there's no way anyone is eating
their way out of this plague there are
just too many of them and you also have
to watch that you don't pick the wrong
ones yeah of course you can eat them no
problem except you have to be careful
when they are sprayed because of course
you poison people insecticides are
controversial but they're the only thing
that seems to work for the first time in
Africa they're trying out a bio
pesticide based on fungus they say it
isn't harmful to people or the
environment there are other issues
though finding the locust can be tough
Africa is bigger than Canada the US and
China combined where do you have your
pesticides where do you have your place
where do you have your cars so it is
really a logistic nightmare to control
them and using insecticides also
requires specially trained people for
precision spring right now that's just
not happening because of the coronavirus
ban on the groups it's like a very
well-choreographed you know dance in
fact and if one thing is missing the
dance is a flaw these locusts are threat
to millions of people some are already
starving and now those same people are
bracing themselves for Kovan 19 a plague
or a pandemic on its own as a disaster
but together it's hard to imagine how
people will cope without some sort of
help
we don't know when we'll be back on the
start here set but not to worry we're
still going to be bringing you more
episodes any way we can in the meantime
our website aljazeera.com has all the
latest on the corona virus pandemic I'll
see you next week
[Music]